we're dealing with this very unique
landscape now of Google and Facebook and
Twitter and Instagram and all these
different social media groups that have
a vested interest in a specific
narrative being portrayed and one thing
specifically is and this is being
addressed right now in Congress is the
discrimination against conservative
voices and there's a lot of denial of
that but there's also a lot of evidence
that that is the case and that they feel
like they have some moral or ethical
obligation to suppress certain
conservative voices for whatever reason
and push the narrative of progressive
and liberal voices this is a very
strange thing because the the amount of
influence that something like Google or
Facebook has today is arguably as great
or greater than the Sean Hannity's of
the world and the cnn's and the the the
the the traditional news outlets yeah so
no doubt me you know there's a big
debate about whether they were more
important in 2016 than the cable
stations my colleague Gill hi ben claire
has a book that argues pretty powerfully
i think that it was actually the cable
stations that were more responsible for
the result than the Facebook's but
whether in 2016 they were more powerful
someday in the future they're going to
be more powerful it's certainly powerful
absolutely I'm and you know the question
is what we mean by bias or
discrimination here like you know in
2017 in the fall it was revealed that
Facebook was selling ads for people who
wanted to target quote Jew haters okay
so you could go and you could buy ads
for Jew haters now there was never how
did that work okay no I mean you know
they have lots of categories you get to
pick when you buy Facebook ads you know
liberals or people who voted people over
60 whatever this was one of the
categories that was exposed
you could buy ads for jew-hater it was
an actual choice
yeah yeah what yeah now there was never
a time that a facebook engineer or a
marketing person decided we ought to
create a Jew hater category
right was not a decision of any human it
was the product of the machine the AI
that was developing the categories based
on what they saw people happen to be
interested in and then throw up
categories to see what sticks and then
certain category stick and then they run
with them so it so you might say you
know if you were the you know if you
defamation League you would say oh my
god Facebook is you know discriminating
to encourage jus haters but from another
perspective you like the machines doing
it no doubt yeah but but to what extent
you want to say Facebook is doing it and
I think that's off that's often what
you're going to see in this argument
about whether they're quote biasing the
system against one side or the other you
know like this hilarious hearing that
was just held on Capitol Hill two days
ago
yes we're great congressmen lose like if
you don't want negative results in the
suit then don't do bad things yeah and
um so you know I think this is nice and
quite funny it was really funny it this
is like nobody's intent we should
explain that to people who don't know
what we're talking about yeah so so
there was an argument about you know
whether Google was tilting the ads to
embarrass one side of the other and I
guess it was a congressman from Iowa
everybody liked that that's the guy who
didn't know that Google didn't make the
iPhone yeah he got but anyway there was
this um you know the exchange was
basically here I'm going to show you a
demonstration and they put in a certain
name and that's congressman Smith and
then up comes this a reference to his
race-baiting yeah and he's like outraged
by this and you know so one theory is
you've got Google engineers down there
saying let's get congressman Smith so
we're gonna make it so every time you
put Smith in there up comes Reese
baiting but Google's responses look we
don't do individualized search results
like we give people what we think people
want based on what they've done in the
past and what they've shown interest in
and and so that's what's producing this
it's the machine that's producing this
result and that let congressman Lou come
back with you know if you don't like the
connections then just don't enable them
to be made I don't doing things like
don't do things like race-baiting
yeah if you don't want negative search
results don't do negative yeah which is
a pretty
but but I do think that it there's a
really hard problem here when you say
it's the machine is doing it mm-hmm you
know what's the future going to be like
when we can just say it's not my promise
the Machine this is just Facebook though
when you're talking about or Google
rather when you're we're talking about
Twitter twitter has a different issue
and their issue is there's accusations
of shadow banning that they have decided
that they're going to silence certain
voices or make them much more difficult
to find or eliminate them from certain
people's feeds you know and they're
doing this this the allegation that
they're doing is based on their own
personal preferences their their beliefs
that you know their progressive ideology
wants them to lean left and just somehow
another distribute that information in a
much more left-leaning way yeah and I
hear these and I don't not an expert on
what they're doing and I wouldn't be
surprised if you know certain complaints
come in about certain feeds and they say
we're gonna take these off that's the
allegation and they haven't denied that
um and you know quite frankly some of
these like feeds you know Alex Jones
stuff you know if you're the consequence
of your news show is that somebody takes
a gun to a pizza shop and should cut in
in Washington to try to prove that
Hillary Clinton is running a sex slave
operation in the basement there's
something wrong with what's going on
there child sex child sex life right
yeah so I understand why they feel like
they're responsible there and you know
was recognized from very beginning these
companies have said we're gonna try to
create a certain kind of environment and
like so Facebook required you identify
yourself so that under the shadows of
anonymity you wouldn't be causing
wreaking lots of havoc inside the system
but look I think the more fundamental
problem here you know so what I've said
so far people like Google and Facebook
might like hear stuff they're gonna hate
the more fundamental problem here is
that we have no antitrust enforcement of
any of these companies against any of
these companies and we've allowed them
to become so incredibly powerful without
any justification under the law well
isn't the issue though that this
was never anticipated that this is now
when they created Twitter they didn't
think of it it's gonna be it's gonna be
some voice of distribution of
information that's unprecedented
worldwide but that's what it is yeah no
they didn't expect no doubt they didn't
expect it to work exactly the way it
worked but the antitrust law has from
the beginning had standards that should
have said we need to step in in certain
places so for example in 2010 Facebook
is facing a pretty powerful competitive
threat from Instagram and the question
is what they're gonna do like it's
cooler to be Instagram it's kids are
using it much the growth rate is much
faster in an ordinary competitive market
what they would do is they would build a
better product to compete with Instagram
their response was to write a check for
a billion dollars and they bought
Instagram and and they've bought a whole
bunch of other companies including
whatsapp which you know was a very
important competitor you know in people
believed a really secure way to
communicate they buy Boston Dynamics to
half they that's amazing there's a
there's a Wikipedia page it has like
endless lists of companies that they
yeah they're buying robots
yeah that makes sense I'm just find out
that's true
yeah but the point is antitrust law in
any of these moments should have and
historically would have stepped in and
said wait a minute wait a minute you
can't buy your way into complete
dominance of these markets and I think
one of the biggest changes that's
happened in the last 20 years is that
the antitrust department has just shut
up its doors and just stopped doing its
work so if we had a more competitive
internet environment where companies had
to compete against each other you'd have
companies that try to compete by
protecting your privacy differently by
refusing to sell your information
differently you'd have lots of pressure
on companies like Facebook to behave not
because idiots senators who don't know
how Facebook works are calling them
before hearings but because the market
itself is creating the competition that
drives them to behave in a way that
actually conforms with what consumers
want so I agree with you these are real
questions and important questions if
are they biasing in one way the other
and if they're biasing systematically
that's a really important problem but
the solution to that problem might not
be more government regulation the
solution to that problem might be
governments making sure we have the
right kind of competition going on here
so that they can't get away with
behaving in this bad way